[Música]
bienvenidos de nuevo a ella soy de
france24 tres años después de la
expansión global del movimiento me tube
esta poderosa herramienta que inició con
un hashtag en redes sociales y que se ha
convertido en una vía de denuncia de la
violencia machista hoy explota en el
mundo un nuevo foco de delación y está
en el medio oriente en irán una vez más
las redes sociales sirvieron para elevar
las voces de las víctimas de acoso y de
abuso por hombres que revisten
reconocimiento y poder en la república
islámica esta es la historia por nuestra
corresponsal en teherán
catalina gómez ángel
en una sociedad como la iraní donde el
silencio y la discreción hacen parte de
los valores más profundos pocas mujeres
se atreven a confesar cuando son
acosadas sexualmente esto ha empezado a
cambiar en las últimas semanas cuando
miles de ellas se han volcado a las
redes a contar sus experiencias escribió
un tweet sobre uno de los acosos
sexuales de los que he sido víctima y
mientras lo escribía muchas preguntas se
vinieron a mi cabeza que me va a
preguntar la gente fue una de ellas y
luego me dije déjalos que pregunten
magnas es una de las tantas mujeres que
han compartido sus historias en las
redes sociales en un movimiento que ha
pasado a conocerse como el mito iraní
tenemos una cultura donde se cubre todo
el chador que cubre nuestro cuerpo el
pañuelo que cubre nuestra cabeza pero no
sólo nos quieren tapar la cabeza sino
también nuestro cerebro siempre hay algo
que quieren cubrir todo empezó semanas
atrás con este tweet de llegan y una
joven diseñadora gráfica de 20 años en
el que contó su experiencia con un
influyente traductor que abusó de ella
tres años atrás mientras todos esos tres
años he estado esperando
un tuit acerca de él y mencionar su
nombre quería prevenir que lo que me
sucedió no le pasará a otra persona
claro que tenía temor pero decidí que
había llegado el momento después de leer
un tweet suyos días atrás
bajo el sol
miles de mujeres se sintieron inspiradas
por el tweet de llegan y algunos
compartieron sus vivencias directamente
en las redes muchas veces con seudónimo
y otros buscaron apoyo en mujeres
activistas reconocidas en medios como
instagram como asa de una farmaceuta
iraní radicada en suecia
una de las mujeres que me contactó me
contó su historia de abuso y violación
en su descripción especificaba cómo se
vestía el hombre su apariencia la música
que tocaba y esto causó que otras
personas reaccionarán a este tema
gracias a los testimonios de muchas
mujeres lograron desenmascarar a este
profesor de música identificado como a
ese hoy las denuncias en su contra
inunda las redes pero la justicia
todavía no responde como ha sucedido con
muchos otros casos incluidos famosos la
excepción ha sido que iba me man un
estudiante de doctorado que fue
capturado por la policía después de que
varias jóvenes lo acusaron de cerrarlas
embriagar las y abusar de ellas
la ley toma de manera seria un caso como
el de que iban en mama y busca proteger
a la víctima esto se debe a que la ley
reconoce que la víctima no tiene opción
de decidir pero el caso de kate bam es
excepcional la necesidad de presentar
testigos o de que el violador confiese
su agresión hace que en la mayoría de
los casos las mujeres que buscan
denunciar un abuso sexual pasen de
víctimas a culpables
y la ley sólo legitima una relación
sexual entre un hombre y una mujer que
estén casados o tengan un matrimonio
temporal si alguien no puede probar la
legitimidad de su relación será
condenado por el delito de adulterio y
de relación ilegítima a menos que pueda
probar la coacción la reluctancia y la
presión
las trabas legales hacen aún más difícil
que las mujeres se atrevan a hablar
temen que al hacerlo ya que el repudio
social y de la familia que por lo
general las acusa de deshonrar los
está con nosotros desde teherán nuestra
corresponsal catalina gómez ángel
catalina gracias por estar con nosotros
y acabamos de ver su reportaje sobre
esta nueva explosión del mito que sucede
ahora en irán y le pregunto por qué
ahora la violencia machista no es un
fenómeno nuevo pero las mujeres están
dando nombres y mostrando rostros en
irán eso es lo nuevo de nuevo es que
están dando nombres ya veníamos de 2010
2017 cuando despertó este ni tú está
mundial se habían dado algunas versiones
gente hablando de acosos pero nunca
habían dado nombres y esto yo creo que
se debe a las nuevas generaciones esta
niña llegan y tiene 20 años y esta nueva
generación le tiene mucho menos miedo a
enfrentar la realidad y a decir las
cosas de frente y yo creo que esto
impulsó a muchas otras mujeres a hablar
aquí estamos hablando de romper el tabú
sobre el abuso sexual esta cultura en la
que se nos enseña que primero los abusos
y los acosos son normales y las mujeres
los tienen que soportar o segundo que
cuando suceden son culpa de la mujer
esto es algo que no solamente puedes en
irán- catalina sino en todo el mundo
pero allá en la república islámica hay
una cultura muy marcada que castiga
especialmente a la mujer en estos casos
cuál es la diferencia bueno a mí todas
las activistas y las cumbres con estable
me dicen si estuvo en todas partes del
mundo pero aquí es diez veces más duro
porque nuestra palabra no vale
especialmente porque la familia no lo
quiere aceptar tiene miedo a ser
repudiada tiene miedo a realmente a
reconocer las verdades esto es una
sociedad que tiene mucho miedo muchas
veces a ver la realidad de frente y
afrontar unas realidades que no son
muchas veces amigables y en ese sentido
pero también hay que hablar del sistema
político muchas de esas niñas como
hablábamos y las mujeres van y tienen la
ley en contra y muchas veces por hablar
por crear este tipo de campañas
pueden ser capturadas y pueden ser
presionadas para que lo creen lo que
ellos llaman una distorsión o un mal
ambiente dentro de la sociedad así que
crea muchísimo puede ser
obviamente despedidas de sus trabajos de
las universidades la presión es
muchísimo mayor bueno y a eso se le suma
un agravante catalina y es que se frenan
las denuncias porque cuando la mujer no
puede demostrar el abuso puede pasar muy
fácilmente de ser la denunciante a ser
la denunciada y a ser penalizada como es
esto y porque la ley está en contra de
las mujeres en estos casos sí como nos
explicaba la abogada realmente está aquí
no solamente se reconoce una relación
frente a la ley en ese sentido es el
matrimonio es así que ese es el
matrimonio temporal de red o cualquier
tipo de relación para ellos la mujer es
la culpable la mujer realmente acepto
tener una relación extra-matrimonial y
ahí es donde puede ser absolutamente
juzgada hay dos cosas que las almas que
el violador que el acosador reconozcan
su culpa o que el juez realmente después
de ver todas las evidencias diga que
esta mujer tenía la razón pero tenemos
que tener en cuenta que la mayor
pues tiene una mentalidad de una
tradición muy religiosa y tradicional
que generalmente nunca se pone del lado
de la mujer así que asumirá esto darán
llevado a que muchas mujeres de hecho
hayan contado su historia pero con
seudónimo y muchas hayan borrado sus
tuiteos sus instantes después de haber
denunciado porque tiene miedo bueno
vamos a escuchar entonces catalina uno
de los testimonios que usted recogió
durante la realización de este reportaje
y después vamos a conversar
nunca me he sentido protegida en casa ni
por fuera de ella si el hombre que es mi
padre y su que reza y lee el corán todos
los días me hizo algo así que me puede
hacer un extraño he tratado de
suicidarme varias veces porque no tengo
idea de a dónde debo ir con su agosto
bueno catalina y entonces le quiero
preguntar por este testimonio primero
pues como fue recabar esta información
no es fácil que una víctima de abuso
decida hablar y mucho menos para el
micrófono de un periodista pero además
como esto refleja la realidad que se
vive en irán
y fue ra tengo que decir lo que fue a
través de una amiga de ella que le contó
que estábamos haciendo este reportaje y
ella aceptó hablar públicamente una
historia muy triste esta niña es
drogadicta vivió mucho y bueno esta
droga dicta lleva seis años limpios pero
vivió muchísimos años en la calle porque
el trauma de esta violación de su padre
ninguna de las familias de la paterna ni
la materna quiso escuchar nunca su
historia nunca nadie el apoyo pues
obviamente tuvo unas secuelas
psicológicas muy grandes pero ese
testimonio es muy importante para mi
abuela porque no es la primera mujer que
me cuenta esta historia en las
reportajes que hemos hecho en las calles
de teherán en las mujeres que son
drogadictas o en mujeres que trabajan en
condiciones sociales muy difíciles
siempre he oído una historia de abuso de
violación de por medio así que es
recoger realmente quiénes son las que
son afectadas en la sociedad y ver qué
tan extendido es ese abuso y ese acoso
sexual en una sociedad que todo lo tapa
cómo está bueno y justamente antes de
escuchar este testimonio usted nos
estaba hablando de las redes sociales
que se vuelven esenciales y que se
vuelven una herramienta
escape para mujeres como ella y como
tantas más por la posibilidad de hablar
por ejemplo en anonimato con un
seudónimo o de sentir el acompañamiento
de otras voces gracias a un trino oa una
publicación de instagram y bueno casos
que hubieran quedado en el silencio
ahora pueden ser escuchados si las redes
sociales han cambiado a la humanidad
entera pero en una sociedad donde la
información es controlada donde hay
tanto represión dentro de la sociedad
pues esto sí que ha cambiado las
cercanías para poder hablar públicamente
especialmente a estas mujeres que han
ido contando su historia pero también a
los hombres miren hay una reacción muy
importante en las redes de muchos
hombres reaccionando y diciendo que
hemos hecho porque hemos llegado a este
punto qué tipo de sociedad somos porque
reaccionamos muchas veces así hemos
tratado mal a las mujeres porque no hay
que olvidar aún en la que estas una
sociedad donde los niños y las niñas
crecen absolutamente separados región no
se conocen y no se juntan hasta que no
llegan a la universidad y tienen un gran
desconocimiento así que las redes
también han despertado
tipo de conversación para hablar de
sociedad estamos creando porque somos
así
bueno catalina y una de sus
entrevistados ya llegando al cierre del
programa habla de como siempre se quiere
cubrir el cuerpo de la mujer y también
se quieren cubrir sus emociones la mujer
es todavía tratada como algo que hay que
tapar que hay que esconder en la
sociedad iraní y con esto cerramos
sí y no realmente no porque las mujeres
son el 60 por ciento de la vida
académica tiene una gran representación
en el campo laboral pero realmente hay
un gran sector de la sociedad el más
conservador el más tradicional el más
radical que quisiera volverlas a mandar
a la casa pero realmente si si si fuera
por los más tradicionales y por los más
radicales las puedes no tendrían por qué
hablar
pues catalina muchísimas gracias a
ustedes por este reportaje porque nos da
información sobre otro lado del mundo
sobre una realidad que también viven las
mujeres en la república islámica y
volvemos próximamente en ellas hoy siga
con nosotros
[Música]